in 1915 a German scientist sat quietly
calculating mathematics which would
revolutionize how we look at the
universe his discovery would describe
black holes and describe a new way of
looking at space but it wasn't Albert
Einstein he was surrounded by the sounds
of artillery fighting in the first world
war this video is brought to you by
brilliant org to get better at Science
and Mathematics through solving problems
go to brilliant org forward slash Simon
Clark for 20% off your annual
subscription black holes are some of the
most extreme phenomena in the universe
they're objects so dense that their
gravity is strong enough to prevent even
light from escaping their grasp and as
the speed of light is the fastest
anything can go in the universe that
means nothing can escape a black hole if
it gets close enough they're kind of
terrifying but how is this possible how
do black holes generate so much gravity
that not even light can escape them
and question if light is either a wave
or a massless particle a photon why does
gravity have any effect on light at all
well the answer to that question comes
from the Eastern Front of World War one
but before we get there we need to talk
about this man in 1915 Einstein's theory
of general relativity replaced Newton's
theory as the modern description of
gravity people get scared when talking
about the physics of general relativity
but it's actually really simple
conceptually you just need to get rid of
some of the ideas in your head about how
gravity works because Newton's picture
which is probably your picture looks
something like this object a exists at
some point in space if another object
object B is nearby
it feels a gravitational force towards
object a and so object B then
accelerates towards object a because of
that force however there's no
explanation for how that force got from
A to B that's just some mysterious
action at a distance where the mere
presence of one object mysteriously
causes a force to appear in surrounding
objects so let's
it's that picture of Newton get out of
here Isaac much better next let's get
rid of this idea of a gravitational
forces kind of weird the acceleration
stays though that's after all what we
observe in the real world when stuff
falls towards the Earth it accelerates
towards the Earth and so that's the
phenomena that we have to explain using
a theory of gravity next we need to
clarify something that might seem
unimportant what do we mean by this grid
behind the objects what exactly is it
well in Newton's theory the lines
represent an immutable coordinate grid
the objects are placed on you can
specify the location of an object in
space with its coordinates on this grid
same as in a game of battleships but
instead of two coordinates in the real
world you need three coordinates x y and
z to uniquely specify the position of
something so the lines represent a
three-dimensional coordinate grid in
Newton's world this is defined by
regularly spaced infinite parallel lines
they stretch on forever never touch each
other but when the XY and z coordinates
cross each other they always do so at
exactly 90 degrees it's a reference grid
which tells you how far apart two points
are from each other it'll stay the same
forever and it looks the same everywhere
Einstein had a more complex idea for the
grid his idea split into two key parts
we are coming back to the war in just a
second one the shape of the grid the
grid which tells you how far apart two
points are from each other in space
determines the acceleration of objects
placed on the grid and to the shape or
more precisely the geometry of the grid
is determined by the mass of objects
placed on it so this is the famous image
of general relativity where space is a
rubber sheet and a massive thing like a
planet is like a bowling ball by putting
the planet in space or putting the
bowling ball on the rubber you deform
the rubber sheet you deform space around
the planet such that if you put other
objects on the rubber sheet they roll
towards the planet just like how objects
fall towards the Earth so point one the
shape of the
great that's the shape of the sheet
determines the acceleration of objects
and point to that shape or the curvature
to be more precise is determined by the
distribution of mass on the grid or the
bowling ball on the sheet except the
grid isn't just the 3d space grid of
newton's world made of XY and z in
einstein's world it's a four dimensional
grid made of XY and z but also time in
earlier work
Einstein showed that time and space are
super super connected and general
relativity's kind of a that's a massive
part of it but it goes a bit beyond the
scope of this video
Einstein's theory solves the problem of
what causes gravity
it's the curvature of the space-time
grid which itself is caused by the
presence of mass nice job Einstein there
is a problem though the equations
describing this were too difficult for
anyone to solve even Einstein
nice job Einstein in his address to the
Prussian Academy of Sciences in 1915
where he unveiled his theory and
unveiled the equations that described it
Einstein showed an approximated solution
he basically did a little bit of
mathematical cheating and got an answer
that's nearly exactly right but not
quite Einstein thought that the
equations was simply too complicated to
get an exact solution for but somebody
fighting in the war thought differently
Karl Schwarzschild was a left hand in
the German artillery serving on both the
Western and Eastern fronts as a child he
had published two scientific papers
before the age of sixteen going on to
receive his PhD at the age of 23 just
before the war he was appointed director
of the observatory in göttingen which
was the most prestigious position for an
astronomer in germany so he was a pretty
good scientist but for whatever reason
at the outbreak of war in 1914 he
volunteered himself from military
service despite the fact that he was
over 40 years old during the war he kept
up-to-date with the latest research and
heard about Einsteins work on gravity
and so while serving on the Eastern
Front in what is now Lithuania he got to
grips with the equations of Einstein's
theory swartz child thought that there
was a way to solve n Stein's equations
exactly the Einstein had Mis
and so when a lull in the fighting
presented itself he did so for the
simplest case possible and non
electrically-charged non rotating
homogeneous spirity symmetric mass it's
a ball it's a ball of mass basically the
equations he used in this derivation of
Gouri and i will leave a link down there
for those of you who are interested but
the short version is he did it
Schwartz tribals able to derive a
geometry which satisfies Einstein's
equations and so described that
four-dimensional space-time the grid
surrounding a non rotating blob of mass
he wrote to Einstein with his work and
received a very impressive letter in
response I have read your paper with the
utmost interest I had not expected that
one could formulate the exact solution
of the problem in such a simple way I
liked very much your mathematical
treatment of the subject which is the
kind of letter coming from Albert
Einstein you just want to put on your
wall Schwartz chance result was correct
and brilliant but there was something
strange in it specifically this term so
here R is the distance from the center
of mass that you're considering when R
equals R sub s this term becomes
infinite which produces some unusual
behavior and this distance from the
center of any mass now called the
Schwarzschild radius space-time is so
curved they're not even light can escape
from within the Schwarzschild radius
defines the size of the black hole in
space-time and it forms the boundary the
objects which get caught in the
influence of a black hole full towards
but never actually reach if you watch an
object falling into a black hole from
afar you'll see it full
slower and slower and slower and slower
towards the Schwarzschild radius but
never actually reach it but gradually
looking more and more red as what little
light does escape from near the edge of
the black hole is stretched on its way
out towards you to longer wavelengths
Schwarzschild to find the key
characteristic of a black hole
something that Einstein hadn't done it
took his theory and schwarzschild's work
on it as well as decades
couldn't work before we arrived a modern
understanding of black holes
Schwartz child was crucial but he didn't
live to see it at the time he was
solving Einstein's unsolvable problem he
developed a rare and painful skin
condition called pemphigus which almost
certainly contributed to his death just
six months later in 1916 at the age of
42 while working in the hellish
conditions of the first world war
Schwartz child found the answer to the
question I asked earlier light waves or
photons don't have mass but they still
follow the curvature of the space-time
grid which itself is altered and warped
by the presence of mass so while the
photons of light or the light waves
themselves are directly affected the
space that they exist in that they
travel through is affected by gravity
and walked by the presence of mass and
in the case of a black hole that warping
is so extreme that not even light can
escape the influence of gravity
I find it immensely powerful that among
all the chaos that the death the carnage
of the First World War
someone was able to use maths and
physics to think about the strangest
parts of the universe that hadn't even
been seen hadn't been observed at that
time they were able to escape the
reality that they were facing because
you might ask why did Schwarzschild do
this there's a water before but to me
this was his method this was his way of
escaping the reality of war as he wrote
in his letter to Einstein as you see the
war has treated me kindly enough in
spite of the heavy gunfire to allow me
to get away from it all and take this
walk in the land of your ideas
if like swartz child you'd like to get
stuck into the physics of gravity and
play around with some of the equations
then why not try a few problems in
special relativity or gravitational
physics on brilliant org brilliant is a
website that gets you thinking like a
physicist through solving problems it's
just like a physics degree honestly you
do problems and then when you get
something wrong you have a look at what
it was that made you go wrong
what misconception leads you into a trap
than correcting it and then going on to
do more problems and actually getting
them right this time around there are
also problems of the week every week at
basic intermediate and advanced levels
and they are not easy and I'm saying
that as someone with two degrees if you
like the sound of this and you also like
the sound of 20% off go to brilliant org
ford slash Simon Clark to get 20% off
your premium annual subscription
honestly school age assignment would
have loved brilliant it's a resourced I
really wish I'd had access to when I was
in school so if that's you make the most
of this thank you for watching this
video I'm trying to find the right
balance of making stuff accessible and
also going into enough detail for people
that are looking for detail so let me
know what you thought of the video and
the level I pitched this at in the
comments below also I have plenty of
ideas for videos but if you have an idea
that you'd really like to see me cover
in the style that I do let me know down
there as well thank you again for
watching if you enjoyed the video please
do give it a like subscribe to the
channel if you're not already and I'll
see you next time
[Music]